la función g se puede considerar como
una versión trasladada desplazada de fx
es igual a x al cuadrado escribe la
ecuación para ge x pausa en el vídeo y
tratan de resolver esto por ustedes
mismos muy bien siempre que pienso en
trasladar una función y en este caso
vamos a trasladar una parábola me gusta
buscar un punto distintivo y en una
parábola nuestro vértice va a ser el
punto más distintivo y se observó el
vértice de efe parece que lo desplazamos
tres hacia la derecha y luego lo
desplazamos cuatro hacia abajo al menos
dos vértices van a superponerse es
posible desplazar el vértice a donde se
encuentra el vértice de eje validaremos
esto en un momento por lo pronto lo
hacemos visualmente así que voy a ir a
-4 en la dirección vertical que no sólo
hará que los vértices coincidan para que
toda la curva coincida primero vamos a
trasladar tres hacia la derecha y vamos
a pensar cómo modificar nuestra ocasión
si la trasladamos 3 hacia la derecha y
luego
trasladamos 4 hacia abajo 4 hacia abajo
ahora probablemente algunos de ustedes
estén familiarizados con esto y voy a
presentar la intuición con más detalle
en otros vídeos pero en general cuando
desplazamos algún valor hacia la derecha
en este caso estamos desplazando en 3
vamos a cambiar x por x menos 3 una
manera de pensar en esto sería que es
igual a efe x 3 oye es igual a y en
lugar de x cuadrada sería x menos 3 al
cuadrado
ahora cuando aprendí esto por primera
vez fue algo contraintuitivo me estoy
desplazando hacia la derecha en tres la
coordenada x de mi vértice se está
incrementando en tres pero estoy
reemplazando x por x menos 3 porque esto
tiene sentido bueno vamos a graficar la
versión desplazada para obtener un poco
más de intuición otra vez lo veremos más
profundamente en otros vídeos esto es un
ejemplo desarrollado así es como se ve
la curva desplazada
en el comportamiento que queremos justo
aquí en x 3 queremos el mismo valor que
solíamos tener cuando x era igual a cero
cuando x era igual a 0 para la f
original 0 al cuadrado es igual a 0 que
igual a cero todavía queremos que sea
igual a cero bueno la manera en que
podemos hacer eso es elevando al
cuadrado a cero y la manera en que vamos
a elevar a cero al cuadrado es cuando le
restamos 13 x y puedes validar esto en
otros puntos piensa en lo que pasa
cuando x es igual a 44 menos 3 es igual
a 1 al cuadrado sin duda es igual a 1 es
el mismo comportamiento que solíamos
tener cuando x era igual a 1 así que
parece que efectivamente nos hemos
desplazado 3 a la derecha cuando
reemplazamos x con x menos 3 si
reemplazas x con x + 3
obtendrás el efecto contrario habría
desplazado 3 hacia la izquierda y los
invito a reflexionar porque esto tiene
sentido
ahora que hemos desplazado tres hacia la
derecha el siguiente paso es desplazar
cuatro hacia abajo y esto es un poco más
intuitivo así que vamos a empezar con el
desplazamiento a la derecha eso es que
es igual a x menos 3 al cuadrado ahora
para cualquier valor de ley queremos
obtener un valor menor en 4 de modo que
cuando x es igual a 3 en lugar de
obtener llegó a la 0 queremos obtener
que es igual a menos 4 o 4 negativo
cuando x es igual a 4 en lugar de
obtener 1 queremos que ya sea igual a
menos 3 así que para cualquiera que sea
el valor de ye que obtengamos ahora
queremos obtener 4 menos que eso por lo
que el desplazamiento de la dirección
vertical es un poco más intuitivo si
bajamos restamos esa cantidad si nos
movemos hacia arriba sumamos esa
cantidad entonces esta es la ecuación de
gx gx va a ser igual a x menos 3 al
cuadrado menos 4
una vez más solo para repasar reemplazar
x con x 3 ene efe x es lo que hace que
se desplace 3 hacia la derecha luego
restar 4 nos desplaza hacia abajo en 4
se desplaza hacia abajo en cuatro para
darnos esta gráfica y puedes
visualizarlo o puedes verificar lo
visualmente que si cambias cada uno de
estos puntos exactamente hacia abajo en
cuatro sin duda vamos a superponer la
gráfica en la parte superior de gx hasta
el próximo vídeo